hallo freut mich herzlich willkommen in
berlin bei dir zu hause das immer jetzt
quasi auf dem alexanderplatz genau am
schönsten strand der stadtmauer
pflasterstrand so ein bisschen er aber
ziemlich belebt die leute fühlen sich
offensichtlich hier wohl und du auch ich
finds geil
du bist schon immer hin wenngleich ich
bin zugezogen auf sagte göttingens
göttlichen sagt da bin ich geboren und
ich bin in der kleinstadt neben
göttingen northeim groß geworden dann
über hannover nach berlin 2004 bin ich
hergezogen eigentlich für musik ich
mache schon auch hiphop aber das ist
mein ursprung aber ich habe den anspruch
dass die leute einfach nur sagen er
macht gute musik ich lasse mich viel
beeinflussen von anderen musikstilen
dubstep elektro und pop wir haben auch
auf dem neuen album so eine indie rock
nummer das nehme ich mir einfach raus
dass meine künstlerische freiheit dass
ich sage ich will mich nicht in eine
schublade stecken sondern ich will
breitgefächert meine musik machen was
bedeutet werden die musik für dich in
deinem leben ja ist natürlich der
entscheidende faktor
ich verdiene über das label mit musik
geld ich bin selber künstler
ich opfere viel von meiner freizeit um
texte zu schreiben um musik zu hören um
mich schlau zu machen
auf youtube werden und sich immer wieder
um neue künstler zu suchen gucke mir
phänomene an versuche zu analysieren
warum hat der und der warum haben sie
viele klicks warum sind die erfolgreich
und also es ist eigentlich der in der
lebensinhalt für mich musik nach berlin
gekommen ist was hattest du davon pläne
hast du gedacht hast du dass sich das so
entwickelt könnte
okay ich bin mit der intention her
gekommen und zwar habe ich damals als
ich angefangen habe musik zu machen habe
ich irgendwann bushido kennengelernt
wir haben 2000 war das circa in hannover
ein label gegründet und 2001 ist bushido
dann zurück oder 2002 seinen vertrag bei
aggro berlin bekommt ich habe dann
irgendwie studiert und 2004 hat er mich
angerufen weil sie so den traum den wir
hatten ein eigenes label zu gründen
können uns jetzt erfüllen weil ich habe
berlin weg ich habe mir zwei universe
einen vertrag und kann nebenbei mir so
was aufbauen
lasterbalk nach berlin zu kommen und mit
diesem background irgendwie universal
als vorbild konnten daher alles erfragen
wie man bestimmte sachen handhabt und
ich war ich weiß wusste wie ehrgeizig er
als musiker ist und ich als
geschäftsmann und dann war das für mich
klar dass das funktioniert das label was
wir damals gegründet haben gehört mir
nicht mehr
wir haben uns 2008 getrennt jeder geht
seinen eigenen weg
aber diese erfahrung nutzen wir
natürlich jetzt bei meinen sachen dein
album heißt ja ich sag mal kopfkino
etwas ähnliches mit niveau du sagst das
vorhin du bist nicht festlegen auch das
zeigt ja eine gewisse orientierung in
zwei richtungen niveau und ein starkes
wort ist das programm das du auch dem
den zuhörern auf der nase darauf stoßen
wird
hier findest du etwas das ist beides
also ich lasse mich da einfach nicht
einschränken und aber um sozusagen den
gegebenheiten des marktes so ein
bisschen entgegen zu kommen habe ich
mein album geteilten doppelalbum auf cd1
findest du die
schnelleren wieder die experimentelleren
lieder
da ist zb das indierock lied da gibt es
den elektro einfluss den dubstep ein
fluss und auf cd 2 ist das was sich
sozusagen vor ein paar jahren
durchgesetzt hat warum ich die leute
lieben diese typen lyrics obwohl es die
auch auf cd 1 gibt aber die werden auf
cd 2 noch einmal verstärkt hervorgehoben
bietet ein bisschen zurückgenommen da
sind die ruhiger sind und deshalb habe
ich das sozusagen noch mal ganz strikt
getrennt um weil ich auch gemerkt habe
man muss nicht immer mit dem kopf durch
die wand sondern man kann auch ruhig mal
sozusagen von den fans lernen schreibt
einfach und das kommt zur ausgeschlossen
das ist so sportler sagen die sind im
flow
die haben halt einfach so im moment die
merken nicht dass die erschöpft sind
die könnten noch drei stunden weiter
fußball oder basketball spielen
die müssen noch nicht richtig zum tor
gucken oder zum korb die treffen das
ding einfach und sie sind diesen flow
hast du auch manchmal als musiker oder
vielleicht auch als schriftsteller oder
so ich weiß es nicht aber es ist halt
ein fachgebiet stimmt die situation
stimmt in der du beschreibst
wahrscheinlich die temperatur die
lichtverhältnisse einfach alles und du
bist in dem tunnel und schreib das ding
und weiß dann ende gar nicht mehr wie du
angefangen hast und wenn es dir durch
nichts wächst und das ist besser als nie
laufen können wenn ist hundertmal
korrigiere du als atheist er gefragt
denn es passiert bei uns gerne bei uns
haben schon mal schiffe im hintergrund
angelegt das ist alles kein problem
würdest du dann sagen als es vielleicht
hast du anders mit dem universum
verknüpft ist oder dass da irgendwas ist
was nicht was alle sinne und zwar mehr
als du gleich sensibilisiert aber
natürlich wenn man überhaupt sich
erstmal begreiflich macht das wie wenig
wir von dem farbspektrum oder von dem
von den bällen spektren die emotionen
sind wahrnehmen
dann wäre es einfach absolut dämlich zu
sagen wir hätten die welt begriffen so
und sehen glaube ich in jeder sekunde 4
milliarden informationen auf und 2000
bearbeiten naja ich meine das sagt ja
alles ich bin kein mensch der vor dingen
flüchtet das ist generell nicht meine
natur und ich habe immer das gefühl
leute die das konsumieren versuchen sich
in einen zustand zu flüchten wo es ihm
besser geht als im jetzt hier und jetzt
und ich bin lieber jemand der das hier
und jetzt versucht zu verstehen und dann
was positives daraus zieht ist dass sie
manchmal verführerisch wenn man merkt da
gibt es einen der koks den weltmeister
aber der hat auch ein riesenerfolg weil
er geniale texte super musik und sonst
was macht ja glaube ich mir also ich
glaube dann dass der aber die dass diese
texte schreiben könnte wenn er einfach
keine ahnung vielleicht
zwei mal weniger zu einer party gegangen
wäre dass er meistens auch leute diese
ganz exzessiv irgendwie leben in
jeglicher hinsicht und vielleicht gar
keine zeit haben anders texte zu
schreiben also dein statement keine
macht den drogen weil man muss jeder
selber für sich entscheiden ich will bin
auch kein oberlehrer und dennoch nicht
gern mit dem erhobenen zeigefinger um
das ist seit dem das irgendwie was gibt
oder spaß macht ich bin niemand der so
was hab auch so eine zwiespältige
meinung dazu ob man das unter strafe
stellen sollte oder nicht aber ich für
meinen teil sage ist nicht cool und ich
würde das auch so meinen kindern anna
ziehen das ist nicht cool ist
er ist aber bevor wir wegputzen kann ich
nur sagen lieber natur stone als volk
durchaus nur genau ist auch nicht ich
danke dir viel erfolg haben sich gefreut
mich auch